i felt enough responsibility for making
sure microsoft succeeded that i didn't
want to be the dictator of microsoft
don't ask yourself what the world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
invention is not disruptive only
customer adoption is disruptive
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't be a dictator with bill gates
you made an interesting decision when
you started
microsoft not to have dual a dual class
share
um and so many of these silicon valley
companies do today
what do you think of that i think it's a
mistake and i've said that to everyone
who's asked me it's enough
as an individual to really feel like
you're responsible for the success of
the company
to actually go and so short circuit the
governance mechanism where if you really
are making mistakes that your board
can't outvote you that you literally can
just replace the board the next day
how kind of hubris is that i mean if
you're really doing a good job you
really think you're at risk of that i
didn't want i felt enough responsibility
for making sure microsoft succeeded that
i didn't want to be the dictator of
microsoft rule number two max out your
humanity with oprah winfrey you will
find true success and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
[Music]
like michael stahlzenberg from fort
lauderdale when michael was just eight
years old michael nearly died from a
bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet and in
an instant this vibrant little boy
became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of twenty thousand
thousand thirteen you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams who came to harvard
four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. rule number three design
technology improvements with elon musk
the key to making things affordable is
is like designing
it's like design and technology
improvements as well as scale so if you
think of like say um phones
um like the very earliest like the
earliest cell phones like
i'm probably like dating myself here but
uh like the original wall
street the guy's like walking down the
beach and he's got like the it's like on
a giant phone he's carrying like a
briefcase kind of thing they're massive
like massive massive phone yeah and like
all i could do is phone yep
yep um and like had like 30 minutes of
battery life and that kind of thing
now
at that time
in the absence of technology
improvements like no amount of money no
amount of scale could have made that
phone affordable that'd be a lot of
engineering iterations a lot of design
iterations
and we're probably i don't know on the
30th version of of a cell phone or um
and and with each successive design
iteration uh you can add more capability
you can design you can integrate more
things you figure out uh better ways to
produce it
so it actually gets better and cheaper
but it's like it's like a natural
progression of any new technology that
it takes multiple versions and a large
volume in order to make it affordable
lesson number four
boss up with grant cardone
what's your main message on your heart
right now to people in this time
i would keep i would pay people
i would look at the things just like i
said about number one find out what and
who you need to cut
same thing i would tell a household
what and who do you need to cut from
your life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it
yeah financial is there people in your
life that you could afford to have in
january and you can't afford to have
them anymore
you got to cut them you got to boss up
right now you got to be you got to do
the tough thing if you want to take care
of your tribe your group your family
you have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five don't make decisions based
on opinions with warren buffett charlie
munger and i have been making stock
decisions and business decisions
uh one way or another together now for
55 years
we have never
let
well the macro doesn't enter into it not
just political we haven't we have not
made decisions differently because one
party or the other's in power we have
not not made decisions based on whether
we thought interest rates were going to
go up or down or or you know what was
going to happen with labor negotiations
someplace
you know you don't want to give up what
you know how to do
because of
opinions which you don't know whether
right or not and which are going to be
transitory in any event so you really go
out there every day
and do whatever makes the most sense so
when we buy the auto dealerships last
week
we don't factor in anything
about the fed
about the deadlock in politics about
what's going on around the world those
are all important things but they don't
affect whether those dealerships which
we're buying to own 100 years they don't
affect whether they're going to make
money in the year 2024 or to 2034 or
2044. and the important thing is whether
we get a good business with good
management at a sensible price rule
number six pursue customer adoption with
jeff bezos invention is not disruptive
only customer adoption is disruptive at
amazon we've invented a lot of things
that customers did not care about at all
and believe me they were not disruptive
to anyone
so it's only when customers like the new
way
that anything becomes disruptive um and
so really it's just saying that you want
to you know if somebody comes to you
with a business plan that they claim is
disruptive you should ask them to
explain it to you in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
um why are they going to like it why is
it better
than the traditional way and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is have compassion
with mark cuban how people perceive
entrepreneurs is changing dramatically
and how entrepreneurs are contributing
to society is changing right now as we
speak and i see it on shark tank right
companies coming on shark tank now
particularly from younger entrepreneurs
have a social component
right you don't want to buy something
unless you think the company is
contributing
and even more so now a lot of people are
saying you know what if you're an
entrepreneur and you happen to get rich
that's bad right and so entrepreneurs
people particularly my generation have
kind of segregated themselves into okay
just get me all the money i can into
okay there's can be such a thing as
compassionate capitalism and really it's
falling on you guys now to set the
message if you gonna are going to be an
entrepreneur
having a social component is good
being a compassionate entrepreneur is
better because when you can change
things when you can hire people like i
had to go back through the companies
that i control now and i said i wanted
to make sure that nobody who works for
in particular the arena and the mavs
is on public assistance
because it's wrong i think it's wrong
that somebody who works for me doesn't
make enough money to be on public
assistance
that's the type of attitude i think that
needs to change now with entrepreneurs
and that's now becoming part of your
responsibility and i think that's
critically important
you know guys like me women like me who
can look and backtrack and backfill and
where we've made mistakes and i've made
plenty and i've learned from them
but it's your opportunity and i think
it's critically important to recognize
that you are going to set the tone for
how people perceive entrepreneurs going
forward and if you introduce compassion
and you look at the needs of the people
that work from you right from the
beginning i think you're going to have
stronger companies less turnover and
better results now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
first law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when messily says to mister everything
you even try to do to me is already done
to you
that is not just a rhetorical saying
that is law that is newton's third law
of motion
in physics which says everything
that goes out is coming back it's just
like everything that goes up is coming
down may take a long time to come down
is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so
to answer the power of manifestation and
meditation what meditation does is sync
you up with the source what meditation
does is allows you to literally tap into
the power that created you
so that you are in alignment with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call god we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it we call life when you are synced
up with life
life just gives to you the key thing was
that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was 13 and 8th grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just did it day and night and you
know got better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law exponential
improvement that that was a magic
combination and we we'd look around and
say hey how come everybody's not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
gonna dethrone ibm and uh you know why
doesn't digital equipment get it why is
the guy who runs it this is a company
that's long gone uh but dominated many
computers at the time why isn't that guy
up there saying it's it's wrong we know
it's right and so the key event for us
was it was a very cold boston winter
and a kid computer came out on uh this
popular electronics magazine and we said
oh
this is happening without us i mean here
we are
uh
doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready uh
and then we called them back we actually
did the work and then we called them
back and said how do you make the stuff
go in and out of the computer the i o
and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it to be the very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry and come
and do it in a sense it was one of the
lower risk things i've ever done in my
life i decided to to focus more on
uh giving away then then making money
and so i've uh gotten a chance to travel
the world be out in africa and asia
quite a bit and see the needs that are
out there and now our foundation is very
focused on global health uh focused on
agriculture because the majority of the
the very poor in the world are farmers
who have very small plots of land so any
increase in productivity or certainty of
their crop coming in
can make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to uh people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different if i leave you with
nothing else it's just know this for
sure
there is not one
thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience
not one encounter not one crisis not one
joyful thing that hasn't
happened
just to make you better and help you
rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill your cup and make
yourself whole
that's your job right companies are
learning organisms
and
you can make decisions that either make
it so that you learn faster or you learn
slower and you know in a lot of ways
building a company is like following the
scientific method right you try a bunch
of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
again that's that's an important
philosophy so there are all these
different decisions that we make inside
the company
you know everything down to
um really empowering individual
engineers we invest in this huge um
testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of facebook running in
the world right there's probably tens of
thousands of versions running because
engineers here have the power to um to
try out an idea and and and ship it to
you know maybe ten thousand people or a
hundred thousand people and then they
get a readout on how uh that version of
what they did whether it was um a change
to you know show better content to news
feed or or ui change or some new feature
they get a readout on how
that version performed compared to
the baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how how connected people are um you know
how much people are sharing and how much
they say that they're finding meaningful
content
business metrics like how much revenue
we make and engagement of the overall
community and you know by running tens
of thousands of different experiments
and putting the power in people's hands
to try all these different things you
can imagine we just make so much more
progress than we could if every change
had to be approved by me right or every
idea had to come from from management so
i do think there's something very deep
about building this you know learning
culture and moving quickly towards that
that just helps you get ahead over time
as a general matter is a one piece of
specific
finance financial advice
i would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20 over time you know if
you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life
uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game if you're behind the game by
ten thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i wanna know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
uh
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
uh ahead of time and avoid that and i
get about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and really only society
can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before and they owe a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest let alone
pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and
i will guarantee if you run a big credit
card that you will be in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of
uh your financial situation on the other
hand if you get ahead of the game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're uh
people owe you money or equities owe you
ownership
uh you'll be way out of the game
compared to paying it uh
being always being paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it the
process of me cutting the feed out of my
pantyhose while trying to get the
prototype made before i launched it was
two years so there was a year solid of
me driving in north carolina on the
weekends and at night or taking time off
from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made i learned so many
things that i didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarments
so i learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working
we're really uncomfortable
and they were doing it to cut cost and
production so i immediately changed that
in a spanx waistband a size small gets a
small medium gets a medium and so on
makes perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel one of the things that i think
we've done well
is is just given the people at the
company a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when i was 19 and and now you know i'm
running this big company there were a
number of people who joined
who were you know people i did problem
sets with at harvard or they dropped out
of stanford or you know different
programs who have grown with the company
over this long period of time and you
know one of the things that i'm the most
proud of is we have
about 12 different product groups at the
company
and
all of the people who are running them
um
with the exception of of uh one
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me that's
amazing um and the one exception was
is david marcus who was the ceo of a you
know 50 billion dollar public company so
um you know so i'm pretty happy that
that that he's on board and having him
run a product group i think is a pretty
big coup too but literally none of them
started off reporting to me you know
they all start off in different
different roles some were engineers some
were data analysts um some were product
managers and they've all grown but i
think what happens is you know people
see that you create opportunities for
people and and that also i think keeps
the best people engaged and makes the
best people want to come work at your
company because they feel like oh i'm
going to get those kind of opportunities
too when instead of just holding on to
all of the stock that you got from yahoo
you did what
we call a collar you colored so
you hedged it so tell everybody what
went through your mind because that was
a big bet with huge dollars right and it
was a pr it was actually pretty simple
so you know hedging stock if you know
yahoo paid us in yahoo stock
and
you know i
was smart enough to recognize i guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because i was
worth more than a billion dollars how
much did i need right so i was telling
everybody just find me a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and i leave something on the
table so be it right but
i like that being next to my name and i
wanted to keep it
and so
i sold calls bought puts and effectively
hedged it so that
by the time so
there was a period of time from when i'd
done that and the internet stock market
kept on going up and and i told people
i'd hedged it and goldman sachs the
company had told people what i'd done
and i remember going on cnbc the
business channel and then the guy going
boy don't you feel stupid that yahoo
stock has kept on going up and you had
this hedge and i'm like yeah i feel so
stupid riding around my g5 that i bought
online you know
and and it was just like
not to sound like a crazy greasy greedy
capitalist but
yeah and it was like
i just don't want to screw it up and so
i hedged it and then the internet bubble
burst and i was fully protected and
actually even made a little bit more
money and you know middle um
you know the motto that the
you know what i learned was you just you
don't need to be greedy you know i was
very very blessed i was very fortunate
look i didn't plan the internet stock
market to go up and i didn't plan to go
down so i was lucky in terms of scale
and i didn't want to screw it up and so
i hedged one of the precursors one of
the foundational things to being able to
take risk is to have had
some kind of support from somebody you
have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and uh and i certainly did so
for me i just want to point out that i i
i feel very strongly that um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries amazon is one of the lotteries
that i've won but i had a big lottery
with my parents my dad is a cuban
immigrant he came here when he was 16
years old didn't speak any english
my
his is a great guy
and my
mother
had her
had me when she was 17 years old so she
was a pregnant 16 year old in
albuquerque new mexico in high school
which was not cool
and
she made it work and her her parents my
grandparents helped her with that whole
thing and made made that all work and if
you don't get that kind of support
somehow it doesn't have to be your
parents sometimes people get lucky it's
a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher it can be
somebody but you need that somebody has
to step into your life and that's a
lottery that i suspect a lot of people
in this room have also won just like me
okay so you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep
uh
yeah sometimes not enough sleep is
really great uh because
because if i find it if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way
and and also
like i try to sort of figure out what's
the right amount of sleep
because i found i could have
i could drop a certain threshold of
sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it that would
get less done because
my
mental acuity would be affected um so i
found generally the right number for me
is around six to six and a half hours on
average per night um that's not too bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously i mean do
you do you find i mean i know you're up
here monday tuesday is it all tesla when
you're up in silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a
sort of
um
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during um interstitial periods
like you're in a car you're walking in
the bathroom everywhere you can do email
practically when you're awake
and
and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
and then
and then just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working actually working
so the way i generally do it is i'll be
uh
working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to bay area
spent tuesday
and wednesday at the bay area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spent thursday and
friday
at spacex
in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
uh or
spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex don't stop looking for a job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know that there's not
opportunity there because all it takes
is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent whether
it's emailing calling you know setting
up on seminars whatever it may be
however you can connect with people
applying for jobs wherever however do it
you know every node gets you closer to a
yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity to propel you to where you
look to be
and you know
and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when i came out of college way back
when um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know i remember
reading a story i went to indiana
university talking about how the
unemployment rate in northern indiana
was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today and i had to be
mobile right i had to go from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that that i could platform and so as you
look for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and and that's not necessarily a bad
thing you don't have to get the best job
you don't have to get a perfect job you
just have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an mba
free agent right they might spend one
year or two year at one two years at one
team build their skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking at building your
skills set to prepare yourself for what
comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
first of all when we interview people we
we do ask for some evidence of
exceptional ability which in most cases
includes innovation
this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering to be
innovative
um
and ideally everyone is at least some to
some degree innovative
uh so at the
interview point
we
select for it for people who want to
create new technology
and then the incentive structure
is
set up that such that
uh
innovation is rewarded
making mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
and but but failure to try to innovate
at all comes with a big penalty
you'll be fired okay
yeah all right the carrot and stick
that's the stick if you don't even try
um or or
somebody doesn't even try to invade or
the innovation
aspirations are are very are
not not very good
then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company it's really important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to give the what's
in it for them very concisely and very
quickly so with with differentiating
yourself i'll use an example i always
say you've got to differentiate you've
got to tell the person or the world why
you're unique and why you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have and then you need to let
them know why that matters to them
so
i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say and then you
know how our underground options they're
not that great you have regular
underwear that leaves a panty line that
you can see or these very thick heavy
duty girdles that are too thick under
your beautiful clothes or your nice
slacks and leave lines on your legs
okay then i've just given them the
options that are dysfunctional and then
i tell them well i've just invented this
product and look what it does it meets
in the middle of the options that are
out there and here's why it's going to
be important to you here's why it's
going to matter you're going to be able
to wear white you're going to be able to
wear cream you're finally going to be
able to wear all the fabrics in your
closet that you don't wear anymore and
you're gonna you're gonna look amazing
you're gonna have no lines so then i
would give the what's in it for them but
that's just a quick example and i would
always i like to start with the problem
that i'm solving have them just sort of
invest in it with you and then um why
the other options aren't so great people
need to know from you you're the only
one that can do it why you're their best
choice
don't don't assume that they're gonna
just try to figure it out people are
busy people are you know we got a lot on
our mind tell me even in an interview
when i'm interviewing people i want them
to say i'm your best candidate and
here's why amazon one of the things we
try to do
is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are
a junior
executive at amazon
and that if amazon did this in the
typical kind of corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea
you need to get your boss
to greenlight that idea and then your
boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea and then
your boss's boss's boss needs to
greenlight that idea they're probably
five levels or more
before that idea gets the go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital
you go to sandhill road
and you go to the first venture
capitalist and they tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go
so that that venture capital model is
there's multiple paths to yes there were
20 people who could give you a yes and
it didn't matter how many gave you a no
so if you want innovative thinking you
have to think about how can we get you
want hi
a large number of high judgment people
empowered to green light things
you want multiple paths to yes you want
a system where as a junior
air force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you gotta figure out that's an
organizational
challenge
that big organizations have to figure
out a way to do and by the way
i get you know
this happens all the time i'll say i
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will greenlight it and i'm
fine with that because usually
the cost of the experiments is pretty
small things only get expensive when
they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that
now and then the spending can get heavy
and then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the
using the judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps we felt a
little bad i i certainly i did about
leaving the university
when
uh i thought very interesting work on
artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric
in both those areas has been quite
modest i mean we haven't gone backwards
or anything but ai
is turned out to be a tougher problem
which is is fascinating and now there
there are some interesting advances and
likewise symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research we get to
have some
level of involvement in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice uh
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh compared to
personal computing a company came along
about five years later two pi and did it
uh they didn't do the software piece
right that's why they failed uh because
we still think it was a good idea but we
didn't have anything even close to hey
let's build the computer that we want to
use that we want to have as a tool for
our own
uh messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from
the early days and generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable to figure out if success is at
least one of the possibilities right
exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes um but but ideally you
want to try to
bracket it and say success is in the
envelope of outcomes yeah um
and i wasn't quite sure if that was the
case um i mean i think success on an
academic level would have been quite
likely because you can publish some
useless paper and
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect i'm
sorry yeah i mean that's what we have
how many phd papers are actually used by
someone ever um i mean that's a good
point percentage-wise it's not it's not
good
and um so
so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some
leaves to the tree of knowledge yeah
okay um and and that leaf is nope it's
not possible
right
there goes seven years of my life
um
so that what so that was one path and i
was prepared to do that but then the
internet was the error came along and i
was like okay the internet i'm pretty
sure success is one of the possible
outcomes and it seems like i could
either do a
do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help build it in some fashion you
know put
you know
like i just couldn't stand the idea of
watching it happen yeah yeah so that's
uh so i decided to put things on hold
and
start an internet company well i was
lucky that i got started early i mean
always helps if you get started early
and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down his office
on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in a sense
and that that helped a lot and and i was
always fascinated by them i knew what i
wanted to do early and i think that's a
that's a huge advantage too
and then
you don't need you don't need a lot of
brains in this business i mean i've
always said if you got an iq of 160 give
away 30 points to somebody else because
you don't need it in investments what
you do need is emotional stability you
have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's uh truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it right but
uh how uh how how did you uh what was
that extra thing where uh so many will
acknowledge that and yet we saw in the
current crisis they they panicked why
you went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like ge and goldman sachs
i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of competence i had a guy the
other day asked me for some advice okay
you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know
you give it to them and they they don't
do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him
he's like i know that's right and then
he went and did something different this
is a big mistake people make man things
the best things that have happened to me
did not require
any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her because that adds
thought it adds time
and and
this is another bad piece of advice i
was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast
and and the faster you can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air
when it's landing slowing down it's in
trouble when it's taken off it's it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the same that
thing wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20 29 years old
because the psychologist thought i
needed to slow down
she was scared of speed
i wouldn't and at that time were you
doing well financially or doing i was
doing great but everybody's saying hey
you're doing too much of this and you're
doing too much of that and you're going
to burn and you're going to do this and
people were worried about me around me
they were going slow i was vibrating
faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today talking
one today he'd been fighting man been
efforting ten years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty today the 18 founders of
alibaba a lot of people think they are
legendary something wow you all hibaba
founders you must be super good at it
honestly
most of us cannot find jobs early days
we're not that smart
none of us graduate from
a great university
um
but the thing is that
we are ready to learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn we improve we'll be
there i told them for the first year
everybody forget about that you will be
vp vice president right you will always
be a tiny manager in your life
because if we're successful
people will hide they will be smarter
than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us and then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so
i would say there's no best people in
the world that is suit
ready for you
the best people is always if you find
the right people
working together
training him developing him and he
training you he
then you have a chance to build a team
when you're down and out first thing
people do is blame it on everybody else
but themselves
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook you also
have the responsibility of turning
things around when i started paul
mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident
and i started the company out of the
back seat of my car how old were you at
that time 37 that was 34 35 at that time
so you're homeless at 34 35 again yeah
and what was this series of events that
led to that second time it was just that
we had money set up a half a million
bucks we needed to start the company
with that kind of money and uh the day i
was ready to start go down the bank and
get the money my partner the hairdresser
paul mitchell flew her from hawaii with
his girlfriend and uh we were ready to
get the money and get going get started
i'd left everything i did my
relationship wasn't working out so left
the house plenty of money for many
months with her had a few hundred bucks
in my pocket took the used car which is
20 years old but a decent one okay down
the hill to get the money wow i was
gonna check into an efficiency and all
set up the money never came in no way
nev the guy changed his mind 1980 81
inflation in the united states is 12 and
a half percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate
17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and interest uh and unemployment was
10.5 percent the united states the guy
said yours hostages are still in iran
which they were at that time he says is
this a terrible i'm sorry it's the last
minute no
so it's a matter of
what are we going to do the idea here is
look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instructions first like nobody really
does read this i never read this i wrote
an article about it i don't read any
instructions you know and so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so and that is the premise
there yeah can't it just be simpler
and and the way to make it simple is and
we see this happening today i mean this
is happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now it's simple
pick me up
it's crazy i don't have to put the
address in it should locate where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go you don't even
need to pay for it either it's already i
don't know how to set up like simple you
guys got everything should be simplified
and the way to simplify things i
remember mercedes benz years ago i heard
about this when they had first figured
out how to put a drop back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they never
they couldn't figure it out it used to
be these old
you know they'd hang them up in the
garage and take them off and it was like
very laborious and somebody at
mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm popping i mean the
watches yeah they're they're moving
they're right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call bye-bye we're moving in
that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane this part of the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets a
flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you don't know if
you didn't know about this last night
you'd have been you'd have been doing
work about it last night planning
negotiating with the airlines when you
get compressed on time and you've got a
commitment you're like i got to be there
at 2 30 everything works out
yeah as i was walking out my my
assistant she goes oh where where are
you going to stay
and i was like
book me a place we're close to you know
to the park or where you're staying
but um we're on this trip we went to
tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is that stretched over europe
it doesn't need to be me doing the
planning though yeah
like i think maybe i need somebody else
to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with success resources to
come here and do these events good tell
me when the events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot i want to let route to
sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai
uh kids have never been there we'll stay
there for three days acclimate for a
second and shoot down to sydney i had
enough data to know that i would need to
do a route like that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get uh the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go recently you shared
in a press conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked
will you just share what you meant by
that
yeah i mean
look it's
let's be real here i'm not i'm not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've
been planning for this i'm excited about
it and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds so i mean
look when when i got started with
facebook i was 19.
and um
and i there were so many parts about
building a company that i didn't know
right i didn't i didn't know anything
about hiring or managing or building a
company and i certainly
didn't really know that much about you
know how to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i mean i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um
and uh you know my experience you know
kind of growing up and running the
company is you know went out talked
about what we did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like kind of go into a
into a shell right and and uh end up
being really cautious about how we
communicate so
you know it kind of it worked out okay
for a while for the company because
you know we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well i
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time uh the basic approach was okay
let's try to not like
do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing in broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
i really believe in helping to build
community and and bring people closer
together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that um some of the
principles that we believe in that that
um that are increasingly controversial
in the world and i just think that we
for one don't have that luxury anymore
um for two uh i i think that that kind
of led for a while to a sentiment
towards the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then you know it's not
possible for people to feel that
strongly about what you're doing but so
now you know i i've just i've tried to
change our approach more recently you
know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this speech around our
principles around free expression well
we go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956 that berkshire came
out of
there were seven people sitting there at
a table
having dinner uh relatives primarily and
i said here's the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little
half page what i call the ground rules
and i want you to read these
and if you feel okay about that
about the interaction what the
expectations are and all of that sort of
thing then we'll join forces and if you
don't it's fine other people have you
know but we don't we shouldn't be
partners i mean you know if i'm going to
have a partnership with somebody i want
to be compatible it is you know and
when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're going to pay
big dividends or split the stock or
something like that so by my actions
and my communications and everything i
want to attract the people
that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away costco was
built
sal price who started the price club
that thing
he sat down and figured out the customer
he didn't want and he set up a system
that would keep away the customer didn't
want who did not want he didn't want
somebody buying a quart of milk with
somebody behind them with a
with a basket of 200 worth of goods
waiting for that so we put in a
membership fee and by putting in a
membership page he killed all the
drop-in business the business that
belonged to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire
to to keep out people who have
expectations about us that are different
than ours i mean
good for them and i hope they find
somebody they've said but
if you're going to run a church
you want you want your seats to be
filled by people that are generally want
to listen to your form of religion and
you don't want it to change every week
and say gee i need a new group and i'll
go out and talk to a bunch of investors
and get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church there's a million
604
000 or so a equivalent shares and those
are the seats and i want them occupied
by people that are on the same page i am
being an entrepreneur is about taking
risks but it's about taking very
calculated risks and being you know
protecting the downside so i didn't quit
my job selling fax machines
until i had already invented the product
i was working on it at night and on the
weekends for two years i was driving
around north carolina where most hosiery
was made begging a bunch of
manufacturing plants to help make it and
i didn't quit my job until i had already
landed neiman marcus saks fifth avenue
and got a call from oprah
just a typical day
then i was like okay i feel confident to
quit but i needed the income that was
coming in and i needed my health care
benefits and i was working out of my
apartment in virginia highlands and i
ran spanx out of my apartment for two
and a half years
and it was crazy i mean i'd semi trucks
pulling up twice a week to this
apartment and my neighbors were like
what's happening what's going on but i
was so conservative with my finances in
the beginning i was very scrappy and
still am how did you get through like
tactically to a sale in the encyclopedia
world like people don't want to hear
from you so like how do you overcome
that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was at it for three and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview they told
you all you could possibly make of
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other sales
people what you see what you do what did
i say
so let's say knock on 100 door skin into
one
give 10 presentations to sell one book
but then when you get better and better
at it through your experiences and
losses along the way it sharpens you up
where all of a sudden i got to a point
where if i gave three presentations i
have no less than one order commission
only but i believe that i could do that
i believe that colleges were the best
set of books because a high school
student could read it it wasn't like a
college manual you had to read and i was
doing something good for somebody so you
have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn as you
go okay do i look someone in the eye see
a lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile's the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door and if your day sucks you
fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change when i
got to dallas i was a bartender at night
and i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there you know my car
would only get so far i had a fiat x19
with a hole in the floorboard that
guzzled oil every 60 miles and i went
down there and this place called the
village it's the world was the world's
largest apartment complex we had six
guys in a three-bedroom apartment i
didn't have my own room i didn't have my
own drawer i didn't have my closet i had
a pile and i had one ratty towel that i
stole from
motel 6.
and that was it and so i was looking for
my career got a job at the software
store and i was you know i was didn't
have a tech background so i was teaching
myself all this because the way i look
at tech is somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it and if
if i work harder and faster to really
dive in if it means reading the manual
you know just diving in then i can get a
head start
i was 24.
and so sleeping on the floor working in
a software company you know learning
learning learning learning learning
getting better at what i was doing and
then one day because i was dying to get
out of that rat hole that i lived in um
i had a chance to go out and close the
sale for that would he got me a 1500
commission and so i went to my boss his
name is michael humecki and i said boss
one of my responsibilities was to sweep
the floor wipe down the windows and open
the door to open the store i got the
sale you got to let me close the sale he
goes no you've got to be in there to
open the store
and i'm like michael i mean no so i made
the executive decision to go out pick up
the check thinking if i had this guy a
15 000 check
of course he's going to change his mind
fired me on the spot
and so here i was living in a [ __ ]
excuse my french you know just this
ratty place with a motel six towel sorry
motel six um
and
and really didn't know how i was going
to get out but i went to i decided okay
i'm a lousy employee i went to um one of
the companies that i've been talking to
architectural lighting and i said look
um i need 500 to be able to buy the
software you want and i promise you that
even if it doesn't work i will wash your
car you know i will walk your dog i
don't care what it is i will do whatever
it takes to make it up to you and they
gave me the 500 and that allowed me to
create micro solutions and you know six
months later i was out of the rat hole
and my company turned into a real
company and that's the one i sold um for
six million dollars when i was 29 30
years old the last time i was on this
interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly you didn't want
to do it you were struggling dude my
ankles hurt my knees hurt my back hurt
my like like i had constant pain in my
body why'd you keep doing it
doing what working out no that that
that's no that i wasn't working before
you started working my body was running
pain i wasn't using my body i didn't use
it and it started to abandon me
like i wasn't paying attention to it you
know and it's like okay dude
you know you don't want to pay attention
to me i'm going to make you pay maybe i
don't pay attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to pt uh three days a week that
really didn't do anything and i said you
know what i need to take responsibility
for this if i want to fix something that
that that's the code of my life do you
want to fix something take
responsibility yeah do you take
responsive don't give it over to the
physical therapist the masseuse i was
trying the masseuse the masseuse never
helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i i hired a guy named anthony he
came i said you come to the you come to
my place every day well when i went back
to china in 1995 was an idea of the
internet was very strange china was not
connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is internet nobody say
ah this thing never worked this thing
never exists
um
because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to when i go to the china red
company registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo hope
internet
company
the guy looked at me saying
this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called the internet why
you want a registered company called the
internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but
i in
1995 in later
august china was connected the internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove
i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we
they just tried to take the picture i i
died from hounds to shanghai shanghai to
america to connect the internet it took
us
three hours and a half to download the
first front of the page
at that time there is no netscape called
the mosaic
oh
so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists friends to
stay and wait because to prove that i'm
not telling a lie think in order to
actually do the stuff yes money is
important but i also think the thing
that i hold the dearest and the reason
why
uh
uh the noise about running for president
moved me so uh
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gain the people's trust yes you have and
there is nothing more important to me
than having the trust of the people and
the audience and i i mean i recognize
that it is the audience who came every
day and watched you know from all over
the world that actually yes that that
helped me to be who i am so i think the
uh the the renowned that the the the
standing the the ability to be trusted
and to say something but also
listen don't play the billionaire thing
small don't play the be small yeah it's
it's a very big deal because it allows
you to it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee i would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and i am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that
more poignantly and fruitfully i'm now
looking for ways that i can do that to
create a level of sustainability in
within our communities what do you say
to employees when
you have obviously have some traders in
the stock who are not happy and suddenly
the stock is down 25 after a quarter
well i so for well since 1997 at almost
every all hands meeting we have two all
hands meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind
employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel 10 smarter
because when the stock is down 10 some
month you're gonna have to feel 10
dumber and it's not going to feel as
good
and so it's you know ownership
is uh we give most of our compensation
uh
is is done in terms of uh stock
compensation
and uh uh and part and parcel with
ownership is a mentality of of long-term
thinking you know you owners think
longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and instead of getting a
christmas tree stand at christmas they
just nailed the christmas tree into the
hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes that's a bad tenant
you know they're a good good tenants but
that's a bad tenant and it's because you
know this is the same old thing about
you know nobody ever washed a rental car
and
you you take better care of the things
that you own and and
but but one of the responsibilities of
ownership
and
definitely deep inside the amazon
culture is to think about the
fundamentals of the business and not the
daily fluctuations in the stock price
there's no information in it leadership
is not only about inspiring leadership
is those people who join your company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure in three years
he will be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different the products
will never be different
i told many people when they joined
alibaba i say guys
i don't know fortunate or unfortunate to
enjoy alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder
we had more problems than most of the
companies
if you can survive in the alibaba you
can survive at any company in the world
because life is tough
we never promise
you will be rich
you will be successful you will probably
promote it
but we will promise you
you will be a problem
you have a wrong
you will make a mistake you have a
terrible boss we all promised
so you set the expectation
but have a good vision
so that is the way we manage
the company
and i think
when you hide good people the good
people
believe the vision they will go so when
i visiting a company whether it's a good
ceo or not i do not listen to the ceo
i listen to his people
if the people believe the vision all the
people believe this guy
if the people believe in the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good
a good entrepreneur
can always tell good stories
i don't need to listen story from you
guys i can tell your people
right if your people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision he can tell me what
they're doing
that is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to toilet they talk your vision and
they believe it so what is your
decision-making process or thinking when
it comes to investing your time your
money your energy sure uh it's very
important because time is the most
valuable thing you have is one make sure
where you're putting your time and
energy
is something you want to do
not just because you're exploring with
people you don't like or a business you
don't like or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you could do something with to do
something great not just make money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone just to make
money that it means you've already
decided to take a portion of your time
to make these papers that are backed up
by nothing but will buy stuff
to call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away hey great it was a possession
and you moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
[Music]
if you want another video from
billionaires to get their mindset check
it out right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time
is such a key component
of your life